how did you end up Lincoln with beer for
the remix
my manager linked me up with her Rory
should I worry
um and she was super cool she was like
she wanted to get on the song I think
she was actually at my Pomona show
[__] like four years ago or something
when I first came out she's been
following me on Instagram we've been
following each other so it was only your
time it was only right it was like a
no-brainer yeah
is that something she sends in are you
in the studio with her no I sent it to
her fire you and cash could work on that
originally together no I had that song I
think I had that song for like two years
or something is it hard to get like a
[__] it the freak a leak sample cleared
so that's why we never really try to put
it out I made that song two two and a
half years ago and then they're like
yeah it's gonna be a headache with the
sample they're like going and they don't
have a hook they're like we don't know
if it's gonna like I don't know if we
want to [__] go through it is it
worth the headache if they're yeah if
it's not gonna be a single right yeah
yeah yeah but we dropped in that [__]
went crazy you have to clear that
through Little John or who who you have
to clear the pretty Pablo huh Jive
was like some random dude like who
doesn't make music anymore you old as
hell what the [__] yeah is that a little
jump three months that's a little John B
right I don't know no no no freak a leak
is freaky Little John I don't think so
that was a random dude I don't know why
I thought I don't know shout out to
Peter's number
wait Petey Pablo's number's in his bio
and you call it and he answers shut up
hey someone got her to redo that [__]
the North Carolina [__] the raise up the
baby should do delicious is he from
Little John right yeah Carolina yeah
Shiloh John may that be I like to say
damn that was that everywhere everything
was just Lil Jon the crunk era man what
do you remember about the crunk era bro
I remember all this [__] I was listening
to all that [__]
he was like five bro no was it how was
that like 10 11. you were you're
probably seven or eight I think I was
like I'm 36 and that [__] was popping
when I was like 13. it was popular I was
listening to it who's on your uh like
who's who's your give me your top three
or four favorite rappers ever man
um
I don't know you don't know I listen to
a lot of rappers it's all time uh
features for so future he ain't in the
top uh
say
I don't know just future
yeah I think I listened in the future
every day every single day of your life
yeah I listen to a bunch of other [__]
so I'm trying to think
what would you grow up listening to the
most I grew up listening to anything
like Tupac 36 everything yeah
what's your favorite Future album I feel
like I don't got a top top nothing well
what's your favorite future product 56
nights 56 nights it's great yeah fire
that's probably did it just get put on
dsps finally yeah I think like a bunch
of his mixties yeah I think all the
mixtape [__] actually thank God because
so much of that [__] you had to get the
DAP hip app or go on YouTube the pain oh
God I used to live that shout out to the
dead people I think they just deleted
that [__] or something that's terrible
like I think it just like disappears all
those mixtapes just you gotta go on
YouTube and listen to shitty quality
versions oh God crazy dude do you guys
ever have that where you had like a
bunch of like [__] that because you guys
really started off on Soundcloud was it
pretty easy did all that [__] end up on
the dsps or was there any like songs
that kind of fell through the cracks um
a bunch of songs did it like and then
even the um I would have never pushed in
on dsps when I met mother my first
managers [__] tea Camp Picasso they
put the the shoreline dude actually
mixtape on [__] dsps fire so I all I
ever thought it was like SoundCloud I
didn't even know how to upload a YouTube
we're not
um Greedo just got out shout out to
Greedo I was just with him uh two days
ago I just shot a video of him yeah
shout out to him for his song uh no for
the [__] I got on the project okay uh
it's a games with me him and bino